[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARIEN DEAN: Yeah.
All right.
Uh-huh.
Yeah.
I like the groove.
Let it run some more.
Yeah.
Yeah, you know what?
I need more space
for this one.
OK.
Talk to you all.
Listen.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: Stop it.
No.
Wait.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: You're
not feeling it, right?
DARIEN DEAN: My thing is, if it
was Ground Hog's Day, that
level of enthusiasm would
have been fine.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: But?
DARIEN DEAN: This is Black
History Month.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: That's right.
DARIEN DEAN: So the sign
is-- you're right.
The sign is right there.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: It says
it all over the place.
DARIEN DEAN: So I
got to be real.
I got to be real.
I wasn't feeling that.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: Me neither.
DARIEN DEAN: The
energy was 63.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: Not even.
DARIEN DEAN: 44.
TIFFANY T'ZELLE: Something
like that.
DARIEN DEAN: About 44.
So we're going to have
to get that other--
let me do the math--
56%.
Did it.
We're going to have to get the
other 56 from you all.
But it could be that the problem
is me and my delivery
and the way we doing this.
Or probably maybe
you all, too.
So, I mean, I'm not trying
to point fingers.
I'm not.
So let's try this
again, shall we?
Let's try it again.
Let's just try it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DARIEN DEAN: So maybe if I
give you all the message
differently first, and then we
try, can that work possibly?
AUDIENCE: All right.
DARIEN DEAN: OK.
Maybe.
OK.
I don't know.
I'm sure everybody--
some of you all look confused.
All right.
We'll try.
OK, listen.
[MUSIC - DARIEN, "LOVE
REVOLUTION"]
DARIEN DEAN: That's how
you do a revolution.
So next time, don't get caught
out there with your 44%.
You got to come straight
with the 100.
You might only get one shot.
My name is Darien Dean.
I want to thank you all.
I want to thank all you all
for participation and for
giving me a moment to get up
here and do what I do.
I want to thank this incredible
band, Tiffany
T'zelle, Les Cleveland,
Andrew, Eli.
They're just killing it.
Thank yourselves once again.
Be blessed.
Darien.